il faut reconstruire certes mais il ya
beaucoup de questions qui se posent là
encore notamment sur les technologies
qu'il faut utiliser le toit de notre
dame a été fait en bois
aujourd'hui la charpente pardon pour
être précis aujourd'hui il ya d'autres
techniques possibles
faut-il les utiliser en tout cas jean
michel wilmotte le grand architecte y
est favorable
il l'a dit ce matin sur france inter
parce que chartres a brûlé en dix ans on
a refait la structure en fonte et la
couverture leur ferme en cuivre
la structure et serait scier des
métallique elle va peser déjà deux fois
moins lourd que s'il est en bois en plus
elle peut être préparé en atelier est
arrivé est directement monté sur place
d'hier par et dépeint voie d'eau ça peut
être un formidable chantier
ils sont les nerfs et je pense
qu'aujourd'hui il faut utiliser les
matériaux notre époque
dans un premier temps va se focaliser
sur 7 sur cette technologie après on
verra s'il faut reconstruire
différemment sur l'aspect esthétique on
peut préciser qu' il ya déjà un monument
religieux parisien qui a profité de
cette nouvelle technologie c'est le
collège des bernardins quitter un
somptueux monument du xiiie siècle dont
la toiture a été complètement refaite
parce qu elle avait été elle avait
disparu en fait elle avait été
reconstruite mais de façon non
respectueuses de l'histoire est que
comme vous le voyez sur cette photo la
toiture était métalliques
vous avez une religion lazio olivier
ravanello est-ce qu'il faut refaire tout
comme avant moi j'ai dormi au collège
des bernardins sentais que c'était une
caserne de pompiers n'ont de police
appartenant au ministère de l'intérieur
car je faisais mon service militaire au
ministère de l'intérieur
et donc c'était assez surréaliste
puisque vous aviez des distributeurs de
coca et madeleine qui était plantée au
milieu de ce collège et on dormait sur
les soupentes qui avait été passablement
massacrés pour avoir une bonne isolation
thermique
donc je peux en attester ç'a bien été
saccagés et très bien refait je suis
plutôt favorable à et je trouve que en
plus la france a fait la démonstration
qu'elle était capable de mixer un
héritage patrimonial avec des gestes
architecturaux qui avait du sens et
qu'il y avait de l'impact le louvre on
est un très bel exemple et moi j'aurais
j'aurai plus tendance à
me dire en effet plutôt que de refaire à
l'identique parce que ray moins de sens
d'aller d'utiliser des matériaux
d'aujourd'hui mais de retrouver le geste
qui était celui des bâtisseurs de
cathédrales leur obsession c'était de
faire entrer la lumière
le gothique en était l'expression
d'imaginer un toit qui serait en vert
qui permettrait de faire rentrer cette
lumière est néanmoins de garder cette
flèche qui était un symbole à la fois
spirituelle architecturale et de refaire
la flèche à l'identique voilà moi la
cathédrale que j'aimerais voir mais là
on va rentrer dans un débat sur le goût
et les couleurs ça peut on verra il veut
et pourquoi pas une consultation et
pourquoi pas une consultation en ligne
puisque venir citrique puisque pour le
coup ce référendum
on veut l'utiliser pour des questions
complexes c'est pas fait pour en
revanche sur des questions où on peut
donner un avis ah voilà sur le site qui
va être créée on met trois projets et
française décide ça devrait de nouveau
ça pourrait avoir du sens on va venir
sur les ailes et revenir pardon sur les
goûts et les couleurs mais juste sur le
l'emploi d'une technologie invisible
puisque en fait et vite
on ne la voit pas cette charpente
puisqu'elle est recouverte par une
couverture en cuivre probablement ce que
ça vous choque daniel bilalian non pas
du tout je pense que lorsque le toit
était construit avec je crois 1300
arbres qui ont été nécessaires à la
confection de cet ouvrage c'était les
matériaux modernes de l'époque donc je
ne vois pas pourquoi aujourd'hui si ça
ne nuit pas à la beauté de l'édifice
on ne mettrait pas démener matériaux
modernes moi ça ne me choque absolument
pas absolument pas ça permettrait en
plus d'aller sans doute beaucoup plus
vite mais en même temps je pense que ça
ça ne dénoterait pas dans
l'environnement de notre dame de paris
et puis les matériaux modernes au milieu
d'eux d'édifices anciens on a bien fait
une pyramide du louvre au milieu du
louvre est-ce que ça a choqué quelqu'un
visiblement un peu mais encore plus que
ça reste encore aujourd'hui
mais là c'était la question n'est pas là
simplement moi je pense qu'on doit
utiliser des matériaux du moment sans
mettre à mal la perfection de
l' architecture de notre dame de balle
consensus là dessus il faut retrouver
il faut essayer de retrouver la
mentalité de ceux qui ont construit
cette cathédrale
c'était un peu pas dire c'était un
mélange d'audace incroyable de
technicité formidable l'audace parce
qu'il ya plein de risques dans ces
arcades qui repose lune grâce au lecteur
toute cette ode à cela il faut essayer
d'imaginer ce que c'est aujourd'hui avec
les technologies de matériaux condat
c'est ça qu'il faut pour eux pour que ça
reparte sur 800 ans
et puis on peut rappeler justement c'est
ça la une des questions c'est la
durabilité
par exemple vous savez sans doute que la
charpente de la cathédrale de reims qui
avait été très largement détruite par la
première guerre mondiale a été refaite
en béton et on se pose la question de
savoir si ça va tenir aussi longtemps
que alors s'aperçoit longtemps mais au
moins ça roulera pas si on coche les
critères du pragmatisme ça va plus vite
ça coûte moins cher ça sera plus solide
et ce sera plus léger bond alors sur ces
critères là on ne peut qu'être cours
pour autres et vous l'avez non plus ça
se verra pas ça sera caché mans pour
autant moi il me plaisait de savoir que
cette charpente était en bois qu'elle
avait mille ans que c'était un ouvrage
justement qu'ils étaient plus longs plus
compliqué à travailler que des choses
qui sont préfabriqués en atelier
donc je serais plutôt pour le retour à
la charpente en bois mais vous me direz
ça sera pas le même bois de toute façon
ce sera du bois neuf donc quoi qu'il
arrive ça sera pas le bois du moyen âge
bon c'est le problème de refaire un
fabricant qui vient d'offrir les chaînes
oui oui il a dit donc que les chaînes
sont disponibles et d'aider des maçons
de cette époque qui construisait un
monument quelconque en se disant c'est
pas moi qui le verrait terminée et on
voit alors aujourd'hui dans une société
où il a dit d'ailleurs le prix
marguerite cinq ans lui il a réglé le
problème en cinq ans et pas de l'époque
il y avait aussi le souci des beaux
matériaux de travail et des matériaux
nobles la fonte préfabriqués en atelier
c'est pas très noble
la croyais dans la croyance de l'époque
on pouvait commencer un travail sans se
dire c'est moi qui le finirai et qui en
auraient les honneurs et engins vous
imaginez quiconque commencé un travail
et se dire c'est pas mal je dirais
déshonneur non non ça c'est de terminer
sa ville et vous voyez en direct des
images de l'elysée où vient de se tenir
une réunion justement consacrée à la
reconstruction notre dame de paris on
vient notamment de voir passer le
ministre de l'intérieur et la présidente
de la région ile de france valérie
pécresse bas venons en maintenant à la
question qui fâche peut-être cette fois
vraiment qui et à quoi doit ressembler
le nouveau toit de notre dame est ce
qu'il faut le refaire à l'identique
est ce que il faut comme le suggérer à
nos internautes
l'eau un toit en verre façon bundestag à
berlin il ya déjà des idées originales
regarder celle d'un architecte qui a
posté sur twitter ce projet d'une flèche
assez spectaculaire j'ai l'impression
qu'elle est plus haute que les 93 m et
quelques de la flèche actuelle il ya
aussi des responsables politiques qui
trouve que ce serait une bonne idée de
moderniser un peu ce bâtiment c'est le
cas de gérard collomb le maire de lyon
ils étaient ce matin sur rtl
on peut reconstruire ils n'ont pas
refaire une imitation mais peut-être
créer la notre-dame du xxième siècle
comme viollet le duc avait osé à son
époque alors on vous pose la question
sur twitter faut-il reconstruire à
l'identique slam de paris et c'est oui
un oui écrasant à 80% en revanche il ya
des internautes qui ont d'autres idées
par exemple christian qui propose une
toiture comme un écran en verre plein
d'un seul bloc alvéolé julie graja dit
ça vous inspire c'est
initiative architectural c'est toujours
amusant de voir des photos et des
maquettes bien sûr on se projette on
imagine on se dit on pourrait faire des
tas de choses différentes
donc l'exercice intellectuellement est
amusant mais je pense qu'il faut
reconstruire à l'identique comme 80 % de
vos internautes ne serait ce que pour
s'épargner le temps et l'énergie qu'on
mettra à discuter des différents projets
concurrents
est ce que si on doit organiser des
référendums ou des consultations
franchement je préfère qu'on mette de
l'argent des débats sur des sujets qui
vont nous servir dans la vie de tous les
jours et au quotidien que sur la
question de savoir si on prend une
flèche comme ça une flèche comme si
quelques couleurs on may et cetera c'est
donc faisons à l'identique ça nous
épargnera perdre du temps sur la photo
qui est que vous nous montrez là j'ai
l'impression si l'arrière d'un boeing
on a greffé sur notre moi je pense qu'il
faut leur faire le plus à l'identique
possible lombalgie possède ce talent
c'est un monument qui a une certaine
allure il faut lui conservé son allure
on va pas non plus pourquoi pas rajouté
trois étages au château de versailles
parce qu'il ya que deux étages oui non
c'est une ânerie leur faire au plus près
avec les matériaux du moment voilà sans
ajouter de quelque chose c'est vrai que
l'expression à l'identique n'a pas de
sens en réalité on ne peut pas le faire
à l'identique donc il faut à mon avis
préserver ce qui est l'essence même de
la cathédrale que sa silhouette ce
qu'ils ont c'est la silhouette cette
silhouette option magnifique c'est la
silhouette qui est connu dans le monde
entier
c'est la silhouette qui inspire dans le
monde entier donc cette silhouette doit
être protégé mais peut-être avec des
matériaux modernes
le projet convient de voir à l'écran est
l'oeuvre d'un architecte qui s'appelle
alexandre chassang à la limite la
question qu'on aurait pu se poser c'est
ce qu'on remet la flèche qui datent du
19e ou est ce qu on en reste à ce à quoi
ça ressemblait puisque le jeu c'est
viollet-le-duc qui avait remis la flèche
il ya pas si longtemps s'est pas laissé
leur voiture
je répète rapidement ce que j'ai déjà
dit je pas monopoliser la parole mais
moi je verrais un toit en verre pour
faire rentrer la lumière dans les mêmes
proportions et en revanche essayer de
refaire cette cette flèche que tout le
monde a vu s'effondrer
on aurait envie de revoir ça c'est
sachant que le toit en verre ne
déclarerait pas l'intérieur de la
cathédrale puisqu'il ya une voûte en
tout cas pour l'instant une voûte en
pierre
il ya d'ailleurs quand on levait les
yeux à notre dame on ne voyait pas là on
ne voyait pas la charge en maintenance
et le ministère de la culture a plein
d'idées géniales ils sont les bienvenus
à financer les chantiers du cardinal qui
ont aussi beaucoup d'églises à rénover
en france 1 franchement qu'ils se
sentent libres dans tout ce que vous
voyez vous en levant les yeux à notre
dame c'est la voûte de voir d'autres
choses mais ça ça enlève de l'est de la
russie à ce prix peut être au fond
extrêmement like les projets et fait en
tout cas
effectivement comment ça commence à
arriver et l'idée que qu'on pourrait
consulter les français là dessus vous
êtes une bonne idée vous ai parlé d'un
référendum ça ne marche pas que vous
êtes plutôt pour
il ya un consensus là dessus c'est comme
tous les phénomènes aujourd'hui je veux
dire les gens sont aujourd'hui intéressé
à ça est ce que dans trois jours il y
aura pas autre chose je connais je vois
pas je voit pas l'issue des réformes que
sur les choses passent à une telle
vitesse
c'est ça me rappelle la l'admiration des
français pour l'ordre de leurs policiers
après le 15 novembre la manifestation
place de la république et puis ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui les choses ont tellement
vite que un même un événement comme
celui-ci ne restera pas très longtemps à
l'aller on laisse le dernier mot agipi
qui est maintenant un ou une internaute
qui nous dit au 12e siècle
ils ne se sont pas dit on va construire
comme au deuxième siècle ils étaient
confiants en eux mêmes donc soyons le
aussi il nous reste quelques minutes
pour parler d'un dernier sujet sans
transition comment utiliser au siècle
dernier
jean-marie le pen l'ancien président du
front national devenu rassemblement
national a fait ses adieux hier dans
l'hémicycle du parlement européen à
strasbourg